hey youtubers it's Charlie I just got
back from the thing I totally saw a
Batman vs Superman
this is gonna be my non-spoilery review
it's such a huge movie that is plugin it
take me a couple other videos to get
through all the Easter eggs in case it
wasn't clear this movie is a direct
sequel to Man of Steel so all the things
that happen in that inform what's going
on when this movie picks up so the tone
is the same even the color palette is
pretty much the same but it's not really
meant to be a Man of Steel sequel and
that it's a Superman sequel it's really
like a DC movie sequel because it feels
like almost four movies crammed into one
movie and as awesome as that is there
are a few times when that hurts the film
just a little bit it suffers from some
of the same problems that Avengers age
of Ultron two very fun film but there's
just so much stuff going on and every
once in a while a few character moments
have to get sacrificed in order to
service some other characters storyline
and I definitely walked away feeling
like they service the Batman character
in the best possible way you will
definitely walk away from this being
crazy excited for Wonder Woman in the
first Batman solo film I feel like Zack
Snyder would make a really good Batman
solo film but I don't think that he's
gonna be directing DC movies after
Justice League they're actually getting
ready to shoot that in April like wheels
up in April for big crazy Justice League
part 1 I'm sure there are a few things
that I can't really talk about because
this is a non-spoilery review that lead
into that first film the suffice to say
even given the gritty tone of the film
you will see full blown Justice League
like you have read in the comics when we
get to that film so I feel like a lot of
people going into this film will come
away feeling like they saw a Justice
League film even though that's not
really meant to be the case it's more of
a hard intro to the new Ben Affleck
Batman character soft intro to Wonder
Woman and I can actually say without
getting into spoilers that Ben Affleck
completely nails an awesome version of
Bruce Wayne now depending on which era
of the comics you're reading Batman is a
little bit different his personality
changes but his core operating beliefs
stay relatively the same and know the
film isn't really patterned after the
Dark Knight Returns the Frank Miller
comic they just borrow a lot of visual
references from that Ben Affleck as
Batman feels like he's doing a James
Bond film a really good James Bond film
so even though all the movie versions of
bat
with the exception of Adam West feel
relatively similar in tone really it's
the difference in the Bruce Wayne
performance that I feel like makes the
character a lot - and I feel like Ben
Affleck's version of Bruce Wayne is the
best so far Michael Keaton's Bruce Wayne
was a little bit weird Christian Bale's
version of Bruce Wayne was like this
very practice facade like it was a very
fake personality Hume or Ben Affleck
does not do that his Bruce Wayne is 100%
authentic he might be lying to you when
he's talking but it's not like in the
theatrical way that Christian Bale would
play the character so that is why I am
totally not surprised that when when
they were seeing footage of this Warner
Brothers executives turned the Batman
solo film into a trilogy they're like
okay this is so amazing we have to make
three of these so you will totally walk
away from this saying hell yes ben
affleck batman movie get here faster
please in addition to that Wonder Woman
probably one of the best parts of the
film even in the brief parts that she
was in you will be so excited for Wonder
Woman after this movie now her movie
isn't gonna be coming out till June 2017
so we still have a ways to go
Suicide Squad is actually the next movie
but just the way Zack Snyder used her in
this movie in the way they scored her
because she kind of has her own
soundtrack Batman has his own soundtrack
Superman has his own soundtrack and they
weave all those together in a really
interesting way
hers is my favorite if you were to pick
out the Wonder Woman part of the Batman
V Superman soundtrack you can listen to
that working out and you would go crazy
let's talk about the pacing though
because this is a giant film they have
so much to accomplish with Justice
League set up and all these are their
solo films so I feel like at times that
drags the film down just a little bit
some of the editing choices weren't so
hot like they'd talk about Superman and
then they would cut to some completely
unrelated scene so I will give a thumbs
down to editing but I feel like that's
largely due to the scope of the film
they're just like so many things that
they had to do in this imagine if Marvel
had tried to go from the first Iron Man
film straight to Avengers instead of
doing all the other solo films first
that's kind of what DC is doing right
now and I'll say I love the way they
leave all the characters you'll
recognize a lot of familiar things with
daredevil season 2 I don't want to give
away daredevil season 2 spoilers but Lex
Luthor reminds me a little bit of Wilson
Fisk in daredevil so once you see
daredevil season 2 you'll totally
understand what
talking about the Superman bits do drag
a little on the film but that's largely
due to the way he's used in the film the
way they treat Superman in the film
might feel a little awkward to you
especially if you're a big fan of the
Christopher Reeve version of the
character or really any of the the
cartoon or TV versions of the character
but there is a certain narrative
consistency with the stuff that happened
in Man of Steel it's just that I feel
like the film itself is more in the tone
of Batman than being in the tone of what
you would think a Superman movie would
be like so that is why I say Zack Snyder
would probably make a really good Batman
movie but really Ben Affleck is gonna be
directing those Batman films so I feel
like he'll have a lot more authorship
than actors that have previously played
the character and Geoff Johns is gonna
co-write these new Batman films so I
feel like comic book lovers will love
the new Batman trilogy and you'll love
this new version of Batman Wonder Woman
gal gadot awesome cannot wait to see
that solo film all the other Justice
League members I will say without giving
away spoilers the way they tease them is
actually pretty exciting so you will be
excited about these other versions of
characters especially the Ezra Miller
flash and once you see them you'll
totally understand why the TV show has
absolutely nothing to worry about
TV Flash movie flash will be so
different than any casual viewer that
would see the movie and the TV show
wouldn't confuse them at all so I'll say
overall I give the film a solid B I gave
all the Batman stuff in the film a solid
a Wonder Woman solid a the Superman
stuff I give a b-minus because it does
drag the film down just a little bit so
I'm totally cool with all the choices
Zack Snyder made I totally love the idea
of him staying on the franchise as a
producer after just this like especially
after the first Justice League film as
long as he does not touch the Man of
Steel sequel just let somebody else who
really loves the character direct that I
really don't think there's a way to do
Superman in a dark gritty way that still
feels like the Superman character he
doesn't have to be campy he doesn't have
to be all sunshine unicorn and rainbows
Superman doesn't really work in a Batman
film in the tone of Batman but I feel
like Batman could work in a Superman
film if you guys understand what I'm
saying about that so be sure to go see
the film you will totally recognize some
of the really big comic book Easter eggs
in the way they foreshadow the Justice
League stuff is totally obvious you will
totally get
the references that they're going for
what I'm gonna do next is my first
spoilery Easter Egg video that should
post sometime early tomorrow be sure to
subscribe to get that there is new round
of the giveaway to its to IMAX gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for the flash trailer for next week's
episode they tease some really cool
stuff and you can click here for this
week's episode of the flash and arrow
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight